okay i think we'll get started hopefully
people will trickle in
um so next up we have anna siegel from
harvard university
and she'll be talking to us about groups
and symmetries and statistical models
all right so hi everyone uh thanks a lot
for the introduction and for inviting me
to speak it's it's great to
be able to give this talk today and
thank you all for coming
um
i take it everyone can
hear me okay and can see my screen and
everything so
please interrupt if that's not the case
um and also please interrupt throughout
the talk if you have any questions at
any point i'm very happy to take
questions at any time
all right so
today i'm going to be talking about
groups and symmetries in
statistical models
so
firstly what do i
mean by this
well
okay groups and symmetries motivate many
statistical ideas
so maybe the most prevalent is the idea
of samples that are independent and
identically distributed or iid
and this means that if we permute these
observations this doesn't change their
distribution
and we can think of this
as being invariant
under the group of permutation matrices
or under the symmetric group
so that's
maybe the first example and then a few
others that are a bit closer to what i'm
going to talk about today
so
there's the idea of a group symmetry
model
as studied
in
these two papers here
of anderson and madison in various
normal models and in very normal models
of recursive graphical markov structure
okay so
these particular
statistical models
consisting of covariance matrices that
are invariant
under a fixed group
and i wanted to include this excerpt
here from the paper of madsen which says
that this smoothing or averaging mapping
which may be familiar to
some of you
from
other contexts
is fundamental for likelihood inference
for group symmetry models
all right so that's an example of models
that we want to be invariant under a
group
and we can also consider what's known as
a transformation family
as studied in this paper here for dry
smoking transvenic
which
is a statistical model on which a group
acts transitively so
points in the model can then be
parameterized by a group element
okay so groups and symmetries motivate
statistical ideas and the outline for my
talk
is that groups and symmetries continue
to motivate statistical ideas in my own
work and joint work with with
collaborators so
i'll tell you about uh gaussian group
models
so that's uh based on
our joint work with
carlos amendola catelyn cohen and philip
reichenbach which
where the reference is this uh this
paper invariant theory and scaling
algorithms for maximum likelihood
estimation
and i'll also tell you about uh
follow-up
work on what we call rdag models which
is uh based on this pre-print here on
symmetries and directed gaussian
graphical models and this is based on
drawing work with uh this is during work
with using my camera and philip writing
back again
and
throughout
the talk the focus will be
on
maximum likelihood estimation in these
models and how we can use the group or
symmetry structure to help us with this
optimization problem
okay so
there's been a few uh talks that have
mentioned some connections to statistics
but to not assume any statistical
prerequisites let me tell you about the
setup so we have a statistical model
which i'll call
m
and we're looking for the point in m
that's most consistent with some
observed data
so here's a picture of the setup we have
our model
here and then we have some observed data
and we're looking for the point in the
model that's uh
closest to the data in some
sense
and more specifically the maximum
likelihood estimate or mle is
a point in the model
that maximizes the likelihood of
observing the data
so maybe for this cartoon picture here
this is the
maximum likelihood estimate
okay and
i
i said that i'd be talking about
gaussian group models and rdac models
and i'd like to tell you
some
other statistical models first that they
stem from
which are dag models
okay so
[Music]
i start with a directed acyclic graph or
a dag
which i'll call g and it has m
nodes
so here's an example where m is equal to
four
so i've got these four
random variables here
and edges between certain pairs of them
and then the dark model associated to
this graph is given by the
linear equation x equals lambda x plus
epsilon
where the matrix lambda has
the sparsity pattern
given by the dag so the entry lambda j
is 0 unless there's an edge from
j to i
in the
graph
okay and epsilon is a noise term
that makes the whole thing random okay
so x in this example here is a vector of
length four and that's our random vector
and we know that the
coordinates of this vector should relate
according to the structure of this graph
and we can
imagine that the edges encode some kind
of causal
relationship between the variables
so that maybe lambda21 measures the
causal effect of x1 on x2 but they
needn't be
given a causal interpretation
okay and i'll assume that the noise term
epsilon is normally distributed
with mean zero and variance omega
where the matrix omega is diagonal so
that reflects
the
independence
of the errors
okay
now a graph g is called transitive
if whenever there's an edge from k to j
and another from j to i then together
these imply that there's an edge from k
to i
so for example this graph here is not
transitive because there's an edge from
x
1 to x 3 and another one from x 3 to x 4
but there's not a direct edge from x 1
to x 4.
but if we added in this directed edge
then this would be a transitive dag
okay and if
uh tag g is transitive
then such a model so such a multivariate
gaussian model
is firstly an example
of a gaussian group model
and secondly also an example of an rdac
model
so we can think of these dag models
which are very popular in
statistical applications as being the
starting point for these two other
families of models
okay and
the random vector x is multivariate
gaussian
with mean zero
and all the information about the about
the graph and the variances is captured
in its concentration matrix
or the inverse of its covariance matrix
and the concentration matrix takes this
form so psi is equal to the identity
minus lambda transpose
times omega inverse times the identity
minus lambda
okay so that packages together this
lambda here from the
structural equation and this omega here
from the variance of the errors
okay so this is a multivariate gaussian
model so it has this familiar
probability density function which i've
parameterized in terms of the
concentration matrix rather than the
covariance matrix but is otherwise
well is anyway familiar
so
this
reflects the fact that a mean zero
multivariate
gaussian model is a subset of the
positive definite code so this is the
space in which the model lives it's the
positive definite cone or a cartoon
depiction of it and then model is
some subset of the cone where we
identify the probability density
function with the concentration matrix
that
that parameterizes it
okay and the
positive definite cone looks more like
this so this is a slice of the positive
definite cone in
the space of three by three
uh symmetric matrices
okay and then we're looking at certain
models so certain
subsets or
sub varieties of the positive definite
cone and for example we could consider
those
psi that factor
according to this form that we saw
before the with the dag model so where
we can parameterize the psi in terms of
some matrix lambda
with some sparsity and
matrix
omega that may be diagonal
okay so that's uh one possible uh
collection of
matrices psi that we could consider
so
now i'll tell you about uh another uh
possibility
which is a gaussian group model okay so
we fix a group i have a question
yes please yeah
in this model
what exactly is it that you don't know
you don't know the variances
um uh yeah thanks thanks a lot okay so
that's a great question so
there are various situations in which
various things could be known or unknown
but for my purposes
[Music]
we know the sparsity pattern on the
graph so we know the sparsity of the
matrix lambda but we don't know the
entries of lambda
so we know where the edges are at the
graph but not their weights
and we know that the matrix omega is
diagonal but we don't know its diagonal
entries so we don't know the variances
on the errors
thank you
um yeah thanks enough for the question
any other questions
okay great so gaussian group models we
start with a group g of
m by m
real invertible matrices
and
then
we can define the gaussian group model
given by the group
g
and this is the set of concentration
matrices
which i'll call mg which
are of the form g transfers g where g is
an element of the
group
okay so for various groups of real
invertible matrices we can construct
gaussian group models but there are also
some
statistical models that already have
this
form
so i already said one example is that of
a transitive dag
and
okay if do we know it's a gaussian group
model
what's the group
well the group is this
set of matrices so
uh
invertible
matrices g where g i j is zero
if i is not equal to j and there's no
edge from j to i in the graph
so we can check that the condition for
this set of matrices to be a group is
exactly the same as the transitive
condition
i mentioned before
another example uh which we'll see a bit
more about uh later are certain rdac
models specifically transitive ardags
for which uh something uh called the
butterfly criterion hulls which actually
i won't even tell you what that is later
so
that will just be a mystery for the buzz
of this talk
and the set of matrices in this case
okay is the
something a bit more complicated so a
similarly
uh
defined collection of matrices with some
sparsity and some other conditions
okay and another example
of
gaussian group models are the matrix and
tensor normal models that akshay was
talking about yesterday
all right
so then how do we
do maximum likelihood estimation in
these
in these models okay so the model m is a
set of concentration matrices in the
positive definite cone we're looking for
the point in the model most consistent
with some observed data and i said
before that the mle is the
point or a point that maximizes the
likelihood
of observing the data
so since we're in this multivariate
gaussian
setting let's say we have an
m-dimensional
gaussian then our data samples
y1 up to yn and the likelihood
function is given by the
product
of the densities evaluated at the
samples because they're assumed to be
independent
okay we can rewrite the likelihood like
this and this helps us to see that
maximizing the likelihood is equivalent
to maximizing uh this function here so
log depth psi minus the trace of psi s y
where s y is the sample covariance
matrix
okay so all our attention will now be
focused on
maximizing this function and an mle
given some sample data y is
a
psi that maximizes
the likelihood as we range over those
psi that lie in our model
okay so
we are looking to maximize this function
um over our models or over the points
that
that lie in our set of interests and as
we attempt to do this there are various
possibilities for what might
happen
so the first possibility is that the
likelihood is unbounded from above
conversely the
log likelihood could be bounded from
above
or even better it could be
bounded and attain its bound so then a
maximum is an mle and so the mle exists
and the uh the case scenario that mle
could exist and be unique so
it attains its maximum at a
unique point
okay so
in order to
connect
these
notions to
some properties of groups i will
motivate that just by
looking at a particular
familiar example of permutation matrices
okay so here we have some three by three
permutation matrices
they permute coordinates so in this case
in r3
so for example applying this matrix this
vector swaps the first two entries
and the orbit of
a
point under this group is all possible
permutations of
the entries of the vector
okay now the invariants are
the functions that are constant on the
orbits
and in this case we can
check
that
some of the invariants are these three
polynomials so the sum of the
coordinates the sum of the pairwise
products
and the
triple
product
okay but in fact these aren't just some
invariants so these polynomials generate
the
ring of invariance
and in this particular case
there's
this nice uh correspondence that two
points are in the same orbit if and only
if their invariants agree so if we want
to check if two points are in the same
orbit we need to check
all of their invariants but actually we
just need to check the generators so we
just evaluate these three polynomials
and see if they give the same answer
but the uh
the problem with this
as the way to test
if two points for the same orbit more
generally is that this reverse
implication
doesn't hold in general so this will
only hold for closed orbits we could
have a pair of points whose invariants
all agree but they're not in the same
orbit
okay so that's a motivation
for
notions of stability
so now we have a group g that acts
linearly on some
space v
our orbit is the set of points we can
reach
starting at some point v so
here's the picture here hit this red
square is our space v
we have our
point v and its orbit
so the set of all points we can reach
starting at v
and
the
capacity
is
the
infimum as we range over the group of
the distance of g dot v to the origin
so in this picture here the capacity is
this distance here since this is the
closest point in the orbit to the origin
we
have
that the capacity is this distance or
this distance squared
all right so now based on the
capacity we can make various definitions
so
we say that a point is unstable
if the capacity is zero
and the set of all unstable points is
the null cone
so this is the set of points where all
uh
homogeneous polynomials
uh
that are invariants
vanish
conversely a point is semi-stable
if its capacity is strictly positive
so equivalently if the origin is not in
the orbit closure
okay and now
a
point
is called
polystable this stronger condition than
semi-stable
if the point is
non-zero
and the
orbit is closed
okay so we can see why this
implies semi-stability and then the
strongest condition
is
that a point is
not only polystable but it's stabilizer
so
a set of group elements that fix the
point is finite
all right so on the previous
slide i gave an example of a finite
group
so there we're either in case a or case
d so
once you're not unstable you're already
stable because the group is finite so
the orbit is a finite set of points
so it's closed and a stabilizer is a
subgroup of the group so it's finite
but for other groups and other spaces
various other things can happen so
we can
imagine what happens
if we
act on uh
cm under the special linear group
or maybe the first interesting example
we can look at the action on rectangular
matrices of size m1 by m2
by multiplying on the left by a
matrix in
slm1 and on the right by matrix in slm
ii
okay
so what have i told you about all these
notions of stability and also
all these
properties of the likelihood function
so the main point of the
first half of this talk is to tell you
about these
connections between invariant theory and
maximum likelihood estimation so between
these
are two pictures here this picture of a
point and it's all bit in some space and
this picture of a statistical model and
some
and some data
okay
so uh for this left-hand picture here we
have these
four notions of stability
and on the right hand picture here we
have these possibilities for what could
happen to the likelihood function
so that it could be unbounded
or
bounded or the mle could exist or it
could exist uniquely
and i will
tell you about the correspondence that
holds between
these properties here and these
properties it roughly speaking
uh the strongest results that we have
are situations where there's an exact
correspondence so unstable
corresponds to unboundedness of the
likelihood semi-stable corresponds to
boundedness polystable corresponds to
mle existence and stable to
unique existence of the mle and i'll
tell you about this correspondence in
the setting of
some
gaussian group models but the
correspondence also applies to log
linear models which is something that we
explored in this paper
um toric invariant theory for maximum
likelihood estimation in
log linear
models
okay so lord linear structures also
appeared earlier today at this workshop
in in jonathan's talk in the context of
maximum entropy
and this is this is where they appear
all right so then back to the
gaussian setting
we have a
group of real matrices
and the gaussian
group model
mg is
the set of
matrices g transfers g where g is in the
group
okay so then
this is our
theorem for reductive groups so these
are the correspondences that hold
in the setting of a
gaussian group model defined
for a reductive group g
so a point is unstable if and only if
the likelihood is unbounded from above
it's semi-stable if and only if the
likelihood is bounded
it's fully stable if and only if the ml
exists and we have a forward implication
in this uh last case here that the
stability of a point implies that it has
uh finitely many mles and in fact just a
just a unique one
okay so why does this theorem hold
before i get to that the stability is
not under the group itself but rather
under its intersection with the special
linear group
or
the
matrices in
the group that have determinant one and
this is all in the setting of real
matrices which is more
relevant in most statistical
applications but there's also an
analogous
complex
setting
and in that complex setting in fact we
have equivalents of all four of these
uh conditions
okay so now i'll tell you uh something
about the uh proof idea
well the log likelihood
function
uh as i mentioned before is
log depth psi minus the raise of psi sy
and we know that our matrix
our concentration matrix psi because
it's in the model has the form g
transpose g
so we can write our
log likelihood in fact as a function
of our group element g
and this is what it looks like so it's
log debt of g transpose g
minus 1 over n the norm of g
dot y
where y is our sample
data
okay so now we can see quite a close
connection between maximizing the
likelihood and minimizing
this norm here which is the capacity
okay and this uh this connection between
the notions of stability and the
properties of the likelihood allow us to
use geodesically convex algorithms for
non-minimization
over the
orbit to find the mle
so
uh
such techniques are looked at in uh
these two papers here are this one of
ferguson frank's garg oliveira walter
winkerson many of whom are
participating in this week's workshop
and even more specific to this workshop
the escape of frank's oliveira
ramachandran and walter which
gives
the optimal sample complexity for matrix
and tensor normal models uh by a
geodesic convexity and which um yeah as
i said actually uh discussed yesterday
okay and what about for
non-reductive groups well in this case
we know slightly less
about the connections between stability
and the
structure of the likelihood but we can
show
the uh if and only if conditions for
unstable and semi-stable and a forwards
implication
that a point being polystable implies
that it's
emily exists
so
in comparison to the reductive case we
lose the
reverse implication here and we
totally lose the relationship between
the stability of a point and the
uniqueness of its mle
in general
okay all right so
i'd now like to uh go back to dag models
okay so this is the slide
i uh went through before with this uh
this dag
and
the
dag model that we define on it
so
okay i've talked about gaussian group
models of which this uh situation is a
special case when the graph is
transitive so what about
rdac models
okay well i'll start with an example so
i'll fix the dark g where okay i've
dropped the x's so now we have edges
from three to one and from
three to two
now
the
dag model
on this
graph
consists of concentration matrices
psi of the form
given in terms of identity matrix and
lambda and omega
like this
where the
sparsity condition on lambda says that
lambda j is zero unless there's an edge
from j to i
in the graph
okay so what does that mean in this
example well
lambda has to look like this so all
entries are zero
apart from the one three entry because
that corresponds to the three one edge
and the two three entry and that
corresponds to the three
two edge okay so lambda looks like this
for some unknown values of lambda 1
and lambda 2.
and only there is some diagonal matrix
which is
positive definite so we have some
unknowns omega 1 omega 2 and omega 3.
that must be some positive real numbers
on the diagonal
okay so that's
the
dag model for this graph
now an rdac model
we define
on a dag together with a choice of
coloring
which i'll call c of its vertices and
edges
okay so for example here
is such a graph so it's the same it has
the same adjacency structure
as this one here but now each of the
vertices and edges has been assigned
a color
so one and two are both blue
uh vertex three is black and the two
edges are red
okay
now
what
does the rdac model
on this
colored graph look like well it's
parameterized by
a matrix lambda which has the same
sparsity pattern as the uncolored case
but now because the two edges have the
same color the entries
lambda have to both be the same so these
two parameters here replaced by this
single parameter lambda
and
in the matrix omega we do something
similar so if the colors are the same
then the values have to
be the same so
vertices one and two
have the same color so that means that
their variance is ie the one and the
first entry on the diagonal and the
second entry in the diagonal
have to take the same value
okay so the rdag model
has
taken uh what was this five
model and replaced it by this
model with only three parameters just
lambda and ohm again omega prime
okay so now i'll tell you the definition
in
generality so we fix a dag g with a
coloring
c of its vertices
and edges
okay so on the previous slide
i showed that example
the rdac model
on
the pair g with c
is the set of concentration matrices
which take this form
that satisfy the following conditions so
lambda i
has to be zero unless there's an edge
from j to i
lambda i j has to equal
lambda k l
whenever the edges from j to i and from
l to k
have the same color
and
omega i i has to equal omega j j
whenever vertices i and j
have the same color
okay so about applying that procedure to
this example
here gives recovers these two three by
three matrices that parameterize the our
dag model
okay
so
uh how do these models
uh generalize usual dag models
well if we just give each of our text an
edge a unique color then
conditions two and three don't do
anything and we just have this condition
on
the
sparsity of lambda so that's the usual
dag setting
so that's one hypothetical
question and it's answer
why do we call them our dags
well they're inspired by their
undirected analogues which are called
archon
models
as studied in this paper boy scout and
laraton
called
graphical gaussian models with edge and
vertex symmetries
and the r sounds are restricted because
adding the colors imposes restrictions
on the model
okay and i will tell you about some of
our uh results that hold for our dags
and throughout
i'll have to assume what we call a
compatible coloring
so
what this means is
that
if the edges from j to i and from l to k
have the same color
then
the vertices i and k
also have to have the same color
so we impose that the
child vertices i and k
have the same color but not we don't
have this assumption on the parents
okay and it's a open problem to extend
our findings to the setting of a
non-compatible coloring
okay so
i
said i was going to focus on maximum
likelihood estimation throughout this
talk so what does maximum likelihood
estimation look like for these
rdac models
well it's linear algebra
and
okay if it's linear algebra it involves
some matrices so what are the what are
the matrices involved we
have our
data matrix
y
so here
uh perhaps unusually each row of the
matrix corresponds
to one of the
nodes in the graph so one of our scalar
random variables and each column
is a sample
okay so
that's the matrix that we that we start
with
and from that matrix we build
what we call augmented sample matrices
which we denote by m ys one for each
vertex color s
okay so we're going to use this matrix
here to build some bigger matrices and
what does the process look like
well
the rdac model
is there a question
okay uh
feel free to interrupt again if
anyone has a question
all right so here's an example of an
rdac model on seven
vertices
so vertices one and two are both uh blue
and the other vertices are three through
seven are black and each edge has
also a color assigned to it
so in this case the matrix y would have
seven rows
and we
build from the matrix y
this matrix m y blue so
for each vertex color this example just
shows
what happens for
the
blue vertex color
okay so how is this matrix
constructed
well the first row of the matrix
is
labeled by the blue vertex color
and there we have
the
sample rows y one and y two
corresponding to the
two vertices one and two that are blue
and then each subsequent row of the
matrix is labeled by an edge color
and the entry of the matrix
tells us the vertices
that
are the sources
for
an edge
of that color
so for example for the red edge
we see we have a y3 here that reflects
the fact that there's a red edge from
three to one and there's a zero here
because there's no red edges
that have
as destination as target vertex 2.
okay and similarly there's no
orange edges that point to one so this
is a zero but there's three that point
to two
namely they come from vertex three
vertex five and vertex six so that's why
we have y three plus y five plus y six
and okay i'll maybe spare you the other
rows of this matrix but there's some
combinatorial procedure that takes us
from a graph to these
augmented sample matrices one for each
vertex color
okay so here's our example
and then the
existence of the maximum likelihood
estimate is captured by
doing some linear algebra on these
augmented sample matrices
okay so
here's our
result
we have that the likelihood is unbounded
from above
if and only if
the zeroth row so the top row of this
matrix
is contained in the span of the other
rows
for some vertex color
conversely the likelihood is bounded
from above
if and only if the mle exists
which happens if the top row is not in
the span of the
other rows
okay and the mle exists uniquely if and
only if this matrix has full rank
for all vertex colors
okay and we can also use
this
line of reasoning to give an algorithm
to compute the mle so this is
the algorithm so for each vertex color s
you project the top row
onto the span of the others to get its
projection which i'll call pys
then
the
maximum likelihood estimate
in the
entries of the
matrix lambda so our best guesses for
each entry of lambda are the
coefficients that write this projection
as a linear combination of the other
rows
of the matrix
and our mle in the omega
coordinates is given by this
formula here so it's the
distance
from
the projection to the top row
of my s squared
and we divide by
alpha s
so alpha s is just the number of
vertices
of color s
okay so we can see that linear algebra
once you've constructed these augmented
sample matrices
captures the existence of the mle and
also an algorithm
for how to find it
okay so
you mentioned that the this rdag model
generalizes the regular one if you make
everything unique right
yes uh what are these like
like what do these
set of matrices look like when
everything's unique
great yeah thanks a lot uh thanks a lot
for the question so
i will
tell you so when all the
uh
when all of the colors are only used
once so when every vertex has a unique
color and every edge has a unique color
this construction here
let's see well it will just have one
column because we only have one vertex
of that color
and then
beneath it we will just have
the sample
vectors
at the parents of that vertex that makes
sense so
in the usual dag case each of our
augmented sample matrices are actually
just a sub matrix of the original data
matrix where the top row is the child
node
and
each of the other rows are its parents
all right hopefully that answers your
question and
this uh this theorem is a generalization
of what we know for usual dag models
so in that case we have the
uh
okay hopefully you can
still see my screen in that case we have
the condition that the child node is not
in the span of
the vectors at its parents
is equivalent to the existence of the
mle and
and similarly the uniqueness is given by
the full row rank of each of these
submatrices given by a child node and
its parents
all right thanks for the question any
other questions at this point
okay so
i will
finish up by connecting this back to
looking at groups and stability
so i mentioned before that
the group
associated to an rdac model
is this set of matrices here
so we consider those invertible matrices
where the entry gij is
zero
if i is not equal to j
and there's no edge from j to i
and
such that g i j is equal to g k l
whenever
the edges from j to i and
l to k have the same
color
and when the diagonal entries g i i
equals g k k whenever the
vertices in k have the same color
okay so we can ask when is this set of
matrices a group
so this is a question that we asked
ourselves in the course of doing this
project
and the condition that we obtained
is that the graph
is transitive
and this condition
of the butterfly criterion holds
okay but unfortunately this group is
not reductive
apart from in very special cases so
we don't have a stronger statement of
our correspondence
between
stability and likelihood we only have
the
weaker
correspondence
okay however we can actually show that
for an rdac model
on the graph g with the coloring c
where g is transitive
with the butterfly criterion and if y is
our sample matrix then in this case we
have this full correspondence between
these notions of stability and these
properties of the
of the likelihood function
okay so
in this special case although the group
is not reductive we were able to get
this for correspondence
and in fact there's a sense in which
this theorem holds
even when this set of matrices is not a
group so when this
transitivity condition and the condition
of the coloring does not hold
but i won't say
anything more about that now because
that's all i want to say thanks thanks a
lot for your attention
[Applause]
very wonderful um are there any
questions
[Music]
ayanna uh what is the butterfly criteria
and it's very curious
um yes uh so okay so the butterfly
criterion
looks at
you take a pair of edges in the graph
that have the same
color
and you look at
all of the
you'll see that there's a reason why i
didn't try to explain what this is in
the in the top okay so you have your
pair of edges of the same color and then
you look at
all the paths of length two so you start
at the source
for one of your edges you go to a
different vertex
and then you come back to the target
so that's some sub graph with colors
still
assigned to each of the edges
and the condition is that those two
graphs should be isomorphic so the same
after relabeling the
vertices
that's the that's the criterion
so
it's
a uh
it was interesting to us that it's not
the condition that the whole subgraph on
a pair of vertices is is isomorphic it's
something a bit weaker than that so we
give an example in the paper where we
don't have the
uh isomorphic property but we have the
butterfly criterion and
the set of matrices does form a group
we have another question
um thanks for the talk by the way um but
uh one thing i was wondering about i
seem to remember that you know if you're
trying to estimate
the
like figure out a graphical model i mean
maybe this isn't exactly the right
context but that if you already know the
sparsity pattern
uh it's a lot easier and like
i i feel like people
just
uh do it like with least squares or
something like that
um i guess i'm wondering what uh
if there's
if there's any reason that you couldn't
do that in this situation
um or whether like the mle would help
you solve something that you couldn't
otherwise
okay yeah thanks a lot uh thanks a lot
for your question so i mean we're in
this gaussian setting so the
maximum likelihood estimator will be the
same as the least squares estimator
um so maybe yeah i'll go back to this um
algorithm here although it's really a
linear algebra argument so
the
um
rdag setting imposes that certain
vertices in the graph
have to have the same variance and that
certain edges have to have the same
weight on them
so
it's a
restricted
model of a usual dark model that uh that
imposes this structure
and the
um
[Music]
the motivation is that it is applicable
in settings where you may not have
enough samples for your mle to exist
if you um
if you don't assign colors to the
vertices and edges so another
thing we
worked on in this project which i didn't
talk about too much today is on these
maximum likelihood thresholds so how
many samples you need for
existence and uniqueness of the mle for
these models
but to get maybe more back to
your question another approach
to
studying
graphs and dependencies between
different variables
could be to
look at
regularizing so keynotizing certain
entries of the matrix to drive them to
zero and also penalizing certain
differences between entries of the
matrix to penalize them to have the same
weight assigned to them so that's sort
of
looking at these models from a model
selection point of view and here we're
looking at them from
a maximum likelihood estimation point of
view when the the model has already been
fixed in advance
all right are there any other questions
um how about online
okay wonderful let's think anna again
thanks a lot